the liberal media at it again this time
they're mocking the president amid the
deadly pandemic and they're even touting
the fact that America now has the most
cases in the world a correspondent for
GQ magazine tweeted out who's the s
whole country now CNN's darling Jim
Acosta gleefully pointed out the US has
just passed China a country four times
larger in population for cases of
coronavirus the verge says quote the
corona virus is now the American virus
and those insults apparently inspiring a
Hillary Clinton to tweet he did promise
America first
Greg this is bad go for it
yeah I I I can't believe I'm gonna say
there are no words for Hillary Clinton
you know she's totally stole this joke
it's not even a good joke and the joke
is based on the suffering of others I
would say that she should rot in hell
but I think she's already there and when
you look at when you look at people
suffering death by the way that the
infection rates are increasing because
we're testing more and these are people
that really wanted more testing so
you're naturally going to see more
infection rates but if you see that as
an opportunity to direct attention to
yourself on social media
you're what scientists would call a
scumbag and you're somebody that we will
not forget when this is all over and
done with because you don't want to have
you don't want to say who are the heroes
and who are the villains now we don't
have plenty of time for that later she's
gonna fall on the villain side and I
ain't gonna forget it I thought maybe I
could stop talking about her but now I'm
gonna just chase her for the rest of her
life
dana perino well her tweet to me was
just like so super it responsibly
compare that to former Secretary John
Kerry's tweet today about congressman
Massie in which President Trump
retweeted and said hey I actually agree
with you that was pretty funny I there I
wish I could remember the name of the
writer but on National Review calm
there's a piece about China today that
is so important and if you are a
journalist and you care about freedom of
speech and the right of journalists then
you should actually be really exposing
what China is doing and you should be
very clear that these are the recorded
cases in America we know that China is
not telling the truth we know that we
know that because the journalists were
thrown out they're treated like crap
they have to like figure out a way to
use emojis to get around the censors so
they're not even doing anything to help
their fellow journalists the other thing
is I read a report today about how China
has sent all of these tests to Spain and
Italy and elsewhere to help them and the
tests are defective so how can we
possibly trust the numbers that are
coming out of China and the other reason
that the numbers are not so bad in China
right now is they stop testing yeah and
they don't care about their people so we
do we are honest about our numbers we're
transparent about it we should celebrate
that and not try to rub it in president
Trump's face because we are actually
being honest yeah we try to rub it in
Trump's face they're actually rubbing it
in America's face Emily what do you
think I just think you know these guys
are like stuck in a comic book to Greg's
point about the villain where Trump no
matter what will always be the villain
it doesn't matter what is actually
happening but the difference between a
comic book and real life is that real
life is a real life so he can make good
decisions with positive outcomes which
we are seeing in this response right dr.
fauci says he's working closely together
dr. Burke says tamping down you know
hyperbolic statistics and predictions to
try to calm people's feels calm up
people's fears but there's no way that
the media is going to cover it and
there's certainly no way that Hillary
Clinton or everyone else in those media
figures are going to acknowledge it
whatsoever one bill and hillary did send
thousands of pizzas to the first
responders here in manhattan so you got
to give her credit for that at least
right yeah well look I think a lot of
this is you know sort of facetious
behavior but I still I don't think it's
appropriate I think it's reprehensible
on some levels because we just don't
need it right now
my point here would be you know it when
they say that the United States is
number one I don't I just want to
emphasize I don't know that we can trust
China's numbers the president says he
was talking with the Chinese leader yes
last night president Zee
I don't I don't know if you asked them
hey can we get the actual numbers can we
know where things are because you know
like right now we're using models from
Italy and Europe but China was way ahead
of that we could have information about
how we deal with the cycles the rise the
fall the spikes if China would actually
be honest with us and I don't think
they've been honest so I think that
should be the focus here is because that
kind of modeling could help us with what
we're dealing with at the moment the
facetious comments you know some of them
over the line but I just don't think
it's worth the time yeah I think
President Trump makes crazy statements
no really not I've never heard that
argument why